- Hello, it's Alexa Chung here
with my erstwhile friend..
- Tan France.
- That's it, he knows his name.
We're here to play
Buzzfeed's Keep or Cancel,
it's actually called Cancel or Keep,
2010's fashion edition.
Let's go.
(funky upbeat music)
Silence on set, please.
- Flower crowns.
(Alexa groans)
How do we feel?
- Okay, guilty, okay?
I did a lot of flower crowns in the 2010s.
- Yeah, well how long ago in the 2010s?
- I actually think I did
it in 2009 or even eight.
- Wow.
- Definitely, there was a
Coachella when I had one in,
before Lana Del Rey wrote songs about it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And before everyone
had them on their heads.
- Wow.
- I didn't set the trends -
- I was gonna say, did you
set the trend, do you think?
- Ooh, she thinks she did!
Alright, I like that.
- I don't think I set the trend,
but we used to walk around these fields
with flower crowns on.
- Why?
(Tan laughing)
- Well, we did a lot of crafting,
I didn't really have gainful
employment at the time.
- Okay, you had a lot of spare time.
(both laughing)
- So I want to cancel
them now, cause I just...
- Okay, I want to cancel them also.
- Yeah.
- Overalls.
It depends what kind of overalls.
If we're talking jumpsuits,
I'm all about that,
for men and women.
But women I think you can
get away with overalls,
so I'm gonna say keep, but
for men, you definitely can't,
I think they look terrible.
- This is, so far, a keep for me,
I don't even know what
the second option of-
(Tan laughing)
keep forever,
I've worn overalls since the 2010s
and I haven't taken them off.
- I love them on women,
I think a lot of the time
dudes look a little peculiar in them.
- Yeah, that's true, it's
a bit toddler, isn't it?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Crocs, it's a cancel, immediately.
- Go, bye.
- I hate them, so ugly.
- boom done.
- I saw somebody with
them on yesterday and,
you know, my brand is "nice guy".
(Alexa laughing)
- Air quotes is cause
he's actually really not.
- Nice guy.
(Tan laughing)
I've always got a really strong opinion.
- Your brand and your
real life personality
is nice guy, yeah.
- And I was in Starbucks,
if I haven't had my coffee,
I'm not in like the perkiest of moods.
- Mhm.
- And I saw her in a Crocs-
- Snacky Queen.
- Yeah!
(both laughing)
And I turned to her and so meanly said,
"I'm sorry, I disagree".
(both laughing)
And then I just continued
on with my coffee order.
- You didn't!
- Yeah.
- I love it.
That's great, okay well that poor person.
- Yeah, chunky sneakers -
- Yeah, but you know what,
they very, very comfortably
walked away, like -
(Tan laughing)
You don't know how cozy I am right now.
- Squeakily but comfortably.
- They're like -
(Alexa squeaks)
Chunky Sneakers.
- I know we're gonna say cancel,
but every now and then a chunky
sneaker, I do like still.
And let me say why, you
are incredibly tall.
- Mm.
- And I am not.
And so, if you're around
I'm like, "alright".
- By the way, don't try and act
like I'm six foot something.
- Aren't you like five eleven?
(Alexa laughing)
- No I'm five foot eight,
I'm five foot eight.
- I'm five foot eight,
but then you wear a heel.
- Yeah, it's true.
- So she's often told me,
so I have to wear a chunky sneaker.
So, I'm gonna keep mine around.
- Okay.
- I don't love them,
but I'm going to keep them
because I'm surrounded by giants.
- I am gonna cancel them.
I love them in a Curb Your Enthusiasm way.
- Yeah.
- But beyond that, it just got too trendy,
and honestly my feet are
too big for my legs, so.
(both laughing)
- That's actually true.
Tiny sunglasses.
- (bleep) off.
- Okay great.
(Alexa laughing)
Let's cancel those.
- No, just like,
it's too over-styled, like
everyone walking around,
I'm not being specific,
(Tan giggling)
but you know what I'm saying.
It's like, we get it,
crop top, comet pants,
the tiny things perched on the edge here,
like you're a liar or something.
Just let it go, come up
with your own version,
this generation, come up
with your own version.
- Agreed, that's a deal breaker for me.
- More fierce.
- Yeah!
(blows raspberry)
Yeah, cancel.
- Cancel.
- Scrunchies.
- Love!
They don't break your hair -
- They're just fine, I'm impartial.
- Having just given you the
big, like, find your own style,
as someone that only rips off the '60s,
I would like to apologize for that
because I realize how hypocritical it is.
In London it's kind of like a job
that people without a job do.
- Oh I know.
- I have a scrunchie brand.
- Oh I know, I know a lot of those people,
it's a thing in Utah, too.
- Yeah.
- It's hilarious.
So, I like it.
- Okay, keep.
- Keep.
- [Together] Man buns.
- I hated them -
- Oh god.
- Even when they were a thing.
- why did that happen,
that happened and we let it happen.
- I didn't, I told everyone
in my life who had one,
"you look like a c-word".
- I definitely slept with
people with man buns.
(Alexa laughing)
- Oh no, eww!
- I can remember it.
(both laughing)
- Cheetah print, okay I know, I know.
- No, I love it, I'm just like -
- I do love it, and it's back again,
I hate to say it is, for men's wear.
- It never goes.
- Yeah.
It's a big trend, it doesn't ever go,
in my opinion it's a neutral.
Like, an animal print is often a neutral.
- I say the same thing, I think
it's the navy blue of the print world.
(Tan laughing)
- Look at you making bold declarations.
(Alexa laughing)
- [Together] Fanny packs.
- I'm over it.
- Are you gonna break the news to them?
(Tan laughing)
- No, listen, i love them,
my castmates do it and I love it so much,
and I loved it last year.
- Last year.
- But it was last year.
No, go, gone.
- I'm over it, yeah.
- Athlei..
(Alexa trails off)
- I love athleisure,
not for everyday wear,
I just like nice clothing
to wear to the gym.
- Yeah.
- So if you're doing it
for that, yeah keep it,
if you, I know most of
you at my brunch space,
when I'm lining up, waiting 25 minutes
to get my damn breakfast,
because you chose not to
go to your yoga class,
and you never went to that yoga class,
but you always insist on
wearing that athleisure outfit,
(bleep) back up.
Like..
- Tan.
(alexa laughing)
- Choose a different outfit!
- Tan really needs some breakfast.
- I really want my breakfast!
- He's so hungry.
- And you're still wearing a yoga outfit.
- This is a man who is hangry.
Can you feel the tone?
(Tan laughing)
Hangry right now.
If you give him some
scrambled eggs after that,
he's gonna be like, "I
don't mind athleisure".
- And back to Tan France.
- Um, I think, never liked it.
Do you know what I like, I
like the French approach,
which is they hide the
fact they go to the gym.
Because their whole attitude is like,
"No, I don't go to the
gym, what's a gym?",
and they're like peeling
their leggings off.
(Tan assents)
I'm into it, just like,
why do we have to advertise
that we're working out.
- Just work out and shut up.
- I don't care if you work out or not.
I sometimes do and I sometimes don't.
- Millennial pink.
I love pink in general, I don't care
if it's millennial or not.
- I think I started millennial
pink, there, I've said it.
- Oh my God.
- There, I've said it.
(Tan exclaiming)
I wrote a book in 2007,
it was called "It",
maybe it was 2013, and the cover of it
was canvas millennial pink.
- I can't tell if you're serious.
Did you really write a book?
- I'm serious,
and when they did the roundup of the year
of where millennial pink came from,
my book wasn't included in
it and I was really sad.
- She was robbed.
- No, I didn't invent millennial pink,
but I did jump on the bandwagon.
- I love it, do you hate it, now?
- I don't know, it reminds
me of like avocados on toast,
in a mid-century cafe.
- I'm sorry, I'm gonna
stop you real quick,
so go on, tell us about why
you dislike millennial pink.
- What?
What is that?
- Your nails!
(Alexa exclaiming)
Millennial pink!
So we're gonna keep that.
- Keep.
- Bootcut jeans.
- Bootcut.
- No, here's the thing, no,
I know, I hate them on most people.
- What is it?
- It depends -
- What is is?
- Like, I don't love it if
it's hitting the ground,
(inaudible) a pair of jeans
on, I just do not like it.
- I've not owned a
full-length pair of trousers
for so long.
- In a long time.
It's been a minute.
- Bootcut, yes.
- I'm gonna say cancel.
I wear them and it's
done in a certain way,
you wear them and it's done a certain way,
but most people are wearing it this way
and I think it's heinous.
- Okay.
- So I'm gonna say cancel.
- Wedge sneakers, (bleep) off.
- Oh, hey I really want to know more
about how you feel about wedge sneakers.
- Hate them so much,
hated them at the time.
Hate them still
- I hate them too.
- Like, it's no.
- Pastel pantsuits, I love a pantsuit
any day of the week.
- Was that a 2010s trend?
- I don't know,
but it's still around.
- I like it.
- I like it a lot.
- Let's keep that
- let's keep them.
- [Together] Biker shorts.
(Tan laughing)
- She also invented biker shorts.
- I did, I actually did, like
I don't know what to tell you,
(Tan laughing hysterically)
I'm sorry guys.
Finally I'm given this
platform to tell you the truth.
(Tan laughing)
No, I tried to make biker
shorts happen in the 2010s
and no one was biting, and
then last year, suddenly,
everyone wanted to wear
their cycling shorts with a baggy t-shirt,
and do whatever that
"VSCO girls", whatever.
Well welcome to the party,
I'm afraid you're a bit late.
- And you're already over it.
- No, I quite like them, we
made, yeah I quite like them.
- I like them, but I think
they're very exclusive,
it's really unfair, like most people
can't wear them and feel
good about themselves.
- But weirdly, I think they're cozy.
Chunky thighs, you get chafing,
biker shorts solve that problem,
cause your things don't rub together.
- We shouldn't be vagina shaming.
- No, I'm not gonna be vagina shaming.
- Let's keep it, then.
- We'll keep it.
- That's it!
- Thanks for watching,
I'm sorry for the incendiary
comments and language.
- Make sure you watch Next in Fashion,
it's available now on Netflix, globally!
You're gonna love it, I promise.
(electronic music)